pink gets candid about working with
Christina Aguilera on the voice her and
I have had history and it had it hasn't
always been wonderful
the artist rose to fame together in the
late 90s collaborated on Lady Marmalade
and recently joined forces on the voice
et was with pink on Monday at the Alice
Through the Looking Glass premiere in LA
where she opened up about their reunion
which of the judges was the most fun to
work with honestly I'm going to say
Christina because her and I have had
history and it had it hasn't always been
wonderful but finally I think it just
took us 15 years and I feel like there
was true love and it felt really good I
love when you're around long enough to
have a full circle moment and that was a
full circle moment for me because in all
honesty I'm a fan of hers and it was
just a really refreshing nice visit
before the event pink performed just
like fire the song she wrote for the
film's soundtrack the music video
features the singers husband Carey Hart
and their four-year-old daughter Willow
who joined them at the premiere know
what you thought of mommy's performance
today it was like it was good like like
awesome good or like kind of good
awesome oh hey I got an awesome thank
you it's pretty cool your mom is like
amazing we see her flying through the
air she's fearless what do you think
when you see her flank she actually has
a silk in her playroom she's her own
little Acrobat she's not very impressed
by me
which I like you can do it yourself why
would you be impressed Alice Through the
Looking Glass is in theaters May 27th
you